the octopus is a rather strange looking
animal that exhibits amazingly complex
behaviors they have the most impressive
nervous system in the entire
invertebrate world they have about a
half a billion neurons that are
distributed throughout their body such
that two-thirds of the neurons are
actually in its legs now mix this thing
with camouflaging cells jet propulsion
and a razor-sharp beak and you have all
the makings of a formidable predator and
then throw in the fact that the octopus
is a solitary creature and suddenly we
have ourselves a real cephalopod fight
we know that almost all animals fight
for food for territory or for mates
and the octopus is no different and
knowing they're fighting behavior could
help us better understand these
fascinating creatures and how they
interact my friend Ilya has been
observing the classic fighting behavior
between the California - spotted octopus
most people think that it's octopi but
that's actually incorrect the correct
plurals are either octopuses or octopod
YZ if you want to be very Greek about it
so how do you do your experiment first I
like to set up the chamber just so it's
ready so I get a jug of water I aerate
it by shaking the jug it seems as if the
water is well aerated they're a lot more
active this gives the octopus some room
to breathe I get the first octopus here
buddy yeah put it in set up my GoPro put
the second octopus in cover it up and
leave it alone
there's always one octopus on defense
one on offense usually the one that's
taking up more space that's more
boastful definitely the aggressor most
likely the winner of the fight the loser
is pretty obvious they get pushed around
they curl up hide in the corner a lot of
the time when there's an initial contact
if one of them is too much on the
defensive side the second one will sort
of poke at it rabbit its tentacle and
see hey do you want to fight me do you
want to turn around do you want to start
a wrestling match so we'll just poke and
run away come back poke and run away
when the octopus come towards each other
to begin the fight they don't actually
face each other they approach sideways
the defense of octopus tries to face
away from the attacker until it's the
critical moment it knows there's no way
to avoid a fight really the one who's
waiting the last moment is defensive he
was the aggressor in a fight we'll
quickly and sharply flash bright black
on his arms when he is about to initiate
a fight ooh and already we're seeing
some action looks like this each other
right so now he's going to become is
approaching but not directly at it yeah
they're like almost completely
antiparallel and then right there yeah
like contacts and then their arms clash
together
so we've taken the first steps in
understanding fighting in the octopus
and you may be asking yourself why does
this even matter
well these types of curiosity based
research question can often lead to some
unexpected insights and discoveries and
we've learned a lot about ourselves from
studying marine animals squid have
taught us about how our neurons
communicate and the horseshoe crab has
taught us about how our eyes work so
it's not too far of a stretch to say
that some of these behaviors that we're
seeing in the California - spotted
octopus are similar to arms
[Music]